[MUSIC PLAYING]
What do we do with
threaded work when
the activity that kicked
it off is no longer alive?
I'm Doug Stevenson, and
this is the exact issue
solved by loaders.
By now, you've seen that
activities in your application
can be created and
destroyed at any time,
either in response to the
user or because Android
needed the resources.
This poses a problem
for your threaded work
since the work may extend beyond
the lifetime of the activity.
Say you have a thread
chugging away at some work
and that thread holds
references to views that
will update upon completion.
If the activity ends before
the work is complete,
a few things will happen.
First, because the strong
references to the views,
the activity object
will be kept in memory
until the work finally finishes.
This is a memory
leak, and we don't
have to tell you
this is bad since it
can cause your app to run out
of memory and eventually crash.
Second, the late
updates to these views
are wasted because
they're no longer visible.
And third, you might
have to repeat the work
for a whole new set of views.
To get your threaded
work to correctly cope
with the activity lifecycle
and avoid these problems,
you should use loaders.
Loaders are wise to the inner
workings of the activity
lifecycle, so you can
ensure your work ends
in the right place every time.
A properly implemented loader
is resistant to activity leaks,
always updates
the correct views,
and is never repeated
unnecessarily.
Let's take a look
at how this works.
Instead of kicking off
your work in an async task
or some other
thread you control,
you ask the activity for an
instance of a loader manager.
Send the work to
the loader manager
and it will make sure that your
work may be handled properly
in the face of configuration
changes for the activity.
The loader manager also
caches the work results
so that it won't be repeated
with future changes.
Now, what if an activity
with an active loader
is being popped of the
stack, never to return?
What happens to
this in-flight work?
In this case, the loader
manager makes a callback
into your code, saying that
its results will never be used.
You can use this callback
to abort the work,
clean up, and move on without
wasting any more resources.
Now, it's worth
noting that loaders
are specific to
activities, and as such,
give you a solid framework
for separating your views
from your worker threads and
minimize the amount of work
you would otherwise have
to repeat with the activity
lifecycle.
The downside of
loaders is that can
be quite a bit of extra
code to get them correctly
integrated into your app.
So to help you
get started, we've
provided some sample code
illustrating some common use
cases.
And for more information on
improving your application
performance, keep watching the
Android Performance Patterns
videos.
And don't forget to join the G+
community for advice from other
great engineers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
#perfmatters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]